me and patrick were like that it was a
physical battle we had so i didn't see
jared i didn't have that
hatred for gerard i wouldn't say i liked
him but i hate i didn't have that hatred
for him because maybe he was technically
a different type of player to patrick i
don't know well man united tried to sign
stevie gary went to where stevie's
rumored england
i would i would have worked a bunch of
you later you and stevie well obviously
he would have been there for a while
but gary said every time gary went with
english why did he come back but we need
to send jared out our rooney what would
be saying all of them you know just good
deer ran past gary and training
him up what i was
gary
[Music]
all right all good yeah nervous should
have been gay
not not nervous because nothing to be
nervous about
almighty joking
you disagree
steven gerard was a better player than
paul scholes
three
two
one
i know i'm gonna have to disagree and
here we go
it's loyalty isn't it the way i always i
always think about this because it
always comes up with scholes
gerard and lampard and and scholes and
lampard won a lot more trophies than
stevie gerrard
obviously playing in better teams and i
always think well
if you took
skulls out of the united team and put
stevie and would united have won
more or less or whatever and if you took
stevia out of our team and put schools
in our team woods we have won what we
have done and i just think of what
stevie did in that champions league
final and
the fa cup final in 2006 and i just
think
i'm i'm not sure scholes your friend
could have maybe had that
impact yeah you know
i i agree but i think it's just down to
the fact
there's the loyalty supposedly yeah yeah
i know i am
because i think steven jarrett was
brilliant i thought lampard was
brilliant but it's just that with scores
in a few games i played with him i
thought listen and i always loved the
player who get
get a goal
but it
would gerrard be better and scorsy
i just think with stevie
obviously i i played him a lot more and
what he did for like
i disagree i didn't say strongly
left a little bit of
i just i think stevie for us when we're
playing
and it's different you use that sort of
maybe four or five matchman is where
you're thinking we need a goal whereas
everyone on the team is thinking even
when it wasn't going well stevie will do
some steve will do something and the
amount of times he did and sort of
bailed you out and and also the thing
i'd say about stevie what i'd always put
him
ahead of other players was
i think he could have been that the best
player in two or three positions so i
think he played right back as whole
creed he played for england
right midfield or number 10 or central
midfield he played so many different
roles and played her at such a high
level so you think the champions league
final he starts central midfield he then
goes off the striker and he finishes a
right wing back for extra time
and and the performance he puts in and i
just think that was that was pretty
special oh he was brilliant
he was brilliant but
he was jesus he won me over i'd be
crying in a minute
he was done
but it's lloyd he has to come into it a
little bit yeah manchester united made a
mistake re-signing cristiano ronaldo
three
two
one
[Music]
hindsight's a wonderful thing isn't it
no i still think ronaldo i still think
it was it was worth the gamble
um
at the bigger picture you're looking
it's not a great signing because of his
age and listen whatever but i still
think he could bring something to the
party and i think he has
but i think whatever's going on around
him hasn't been good enough
but i still think ronaldo could also
probably show more better leadership
skills i know he's been upset once or
twice when he was left out he clearly
wasn't going to play in all the games
but we still he's still showing moments
jamie he's still showing moments
obviously to listen to the tottenham
game some of the european games
um
but i think it was worth the gamble it
reminds me a little bit of when there
was panic but it reminds me a little bit
of when everton got wayne rooney
where you know he's not at his best but
whenever we haven't got too much to
shout about but we've got ruby back and
he might do a couple of things i'm
thinking this is man united man united
should be buying someone who's 27 or 37
who's the next ronaldo and it just
smacked of where the club was of
this big fanfare ronaldo's backed all
this excitement really everyone knew it
wasn't going to
push i i always felt it was never going
to push them any closer to
the title he'd finished second the year
before
and having watched ronaldo i still think
if you if you're judging all united
outfield players he's still being one of
the best if not the best because he's
the one who's had four or five moments
this season where you go wow for ronaldo
to be playing at one of the biggest
clubs in the world at 37 and still
having an impact it's unbelievable but
for man united to buy ronaldo i just
thought it was a joke it sums up maybe
i'll do recruitment whatever's going on
upstairs it was either a panic because
they thought city were going again and
whether they were kidded by that this
thing i get ronaldo back and everyone's
excited the social media all the fans in
the first game i thought it was a better
budget but that's part of the that's
part of my united's problem no i know
van gaal recently said man united is a
commercial club more than a football
club and the signing was part to that it
was path to the brand and the share
price and all this
but
yeah but where'd you go where'd you go
right now if your man united and you've
got a 37 year old ronaldo still another
year to go a new manager's coming in and
he's going to worry about want to buy a
centre forward i think you're ronaldo
for how great a professional he is and
what a player he's been i think he could
be a problem i think
i've been disappointed with ronaldo this
season in that
not about the goals i know we get goals
but it hasn't gone well for united okay
that happens i'd like to him to have
been more of a leader if i'm being
honest i'm not really bothered if he
gets the odd goal or something because
his gold record's amazing he's a
legendary figure i just think sometimes
and i look back and even at the end game
and throwing his arms over players and
he was kicking the ball out a couple of
times and we all get frustrated we all
do silly things on the pitch i'm
frustrated but
i'd love to have seen him being that guy
who who lifted the younger players up a
little bit and i just think that's
probably been lacking a little that's
disappointing brentford game i don't
know if you'd come to the brentford game
but he was taking off and as you said no
problem with a player being upset that's
part of the game you get frustrated but
the game was going on at 10 15 minutes
later the camera would and he's still
upset you're like
just put again jimmy he's looking at the
manager if you really strong manager
gone you should cut that rubbish out i
can be upset but you're short in
different ways and i think ronald has
not been great on that side of it i have
to say it but i think it goes back to
frustration he goes back to united the
obviously never go back so he's come
back a bit of a gamble he's think i'll
go back
rekindled the old days or whatever but
you said he's 37. he's probably looking
around the lads around the probably
think
we're not up to speed he knows pretty
quickly as soon as he comes back we're
not really going to be obviously
competing for the league he's thinking
the cup competitions as soon as that's
all fallen by the wayside that's where i
think his body language has really not
been great liverpool and city's rivalry
over the last three years is the best
rivalry in premier league history
three
two
one
i threw a bone i want to say forgot
about this just getting many times
obviously the game has changed i think
the standard they have set as amir isn't
fantastic but you'd still like a bit
more nastiness between the two you know
that was part of the game i loved when i
obviously played against arsenal
no i don't when liverpool were having
their challenges
denise i think i'd like a bit more
needle between these two teams do you
even yesterday players afterwards it's
all a bit that's where that's where i
think rivalry comes out whatever with
the standard of football and the points
tour whatever they are
these two we can't speak highly enough
of these two teams amazing but i'd like
a bit more
you know people look back obviously
united arsenal a couple of sending offs
fights in the tunnel pizzas we want to
hear some pizza stories from yeah yeah
exactly what you see when you're seeing
yeah it's just too nice isn't it i
always found it hard to like i always
had to make myself not like them even if
they were a good lad or the opponents
you'd be with england with them they
were good lads but
i almost had to make myself i don't know
how you felt with yourself in vietnam
you almost had to make yourself
not like like them yeah yeah that was
easy yeah
i did i never because my mindset was
always in games that particularly
against arsenal was you're going to war
yeah so why would you want to be passing
anybody why would you want to again i
know the stuff people say it's old
school it's not i think it's good school
when i see people chat before the game
why would you want to chat to somebody
before do you have to say it i don't
know
it's like people go over when i hear
people oh would they play for the same
national team i used to play against
irish lads fights playing ronnie wheeler
when when i first came into the forest
why would you chat to somebody because
we're going to be kicking each other and
same after the game but when i when i
played against teammates
even ones at liverpool saying like i
remember playing against danny mayfield
so good mate to my mic alone left even
to uh
he'd come back from the dinner went to
newcastle and in my head going into that
game i'm thinking i've got to hit them
hard
so people people don't think you're
being nice yeah of course yeah i'd be
the same if anyone talked for one minute
you were softening up you're going no
that's that could be a street cred as
you said you kicked them harder but
that was the game we used to have a
was our manager
and we'd have you know the tight tunnel
and at anfield
and before the game sky had you know
show you in the tunnel and you run out
and he'd look back and if he caught
anyone speaking to the opposition
but i never had that strange enough with
gerrard when i played against cheryl i
remember when he was a young player to
alter he came
and i remember saying to him he and i
think he was on the board getting sent
off and i remember saying but i never
had that never that disliked for him
like i had for patrick or maybe some of
the city lads hmm i don't know where
because he was a bit
what is just gerard
he's a couple years younger than me uh
so he's like obviously he was a good bit
younger so maybe i didn't see him as
that trap you know in terms of physical
threat he was more of a technical bear
was patrick me and patrick were like
that it was a physical battle we had so
i didn't see jared i didn't have that
hatred for gerrard i wouldn't say i
liked him like i hate i didn't have that
hatred for him because maybe he was
technically a different type of player
to patrick i don't know well man united
tried to sign stevie gary went to a
stevie's room at england but i would i
would have worked i mentioned
you and stevie well obviously he would
have been the resident for a while
no but gary said every time gary went
with english when he'd come back but we
need to sign jared out of our rooney
look we'll be saying all of them you
know just good deer ran past gary and
training
him up but i was
it was gary
no but jared i think he would have
i think you're after patrick for a while
there was stories that uh patriot was
gonna come to um
united i never thought too much of it
maybe that would have been the end of me
i don't know
i was just um
no but obviously that was never gonna
happen was it i could hardly see jared
leaving liverpool for you
pep guardiola could surpass sir alex
ferguson as the greatest premier league
manager of all time
three
two
one
if he stays
if he stays for
not the next five ten years obviously
he's talking about he's got what two
years left in his contract
why couldn't he jimmy just he's
intense numbers numbers
do the only thing i i would say on pep
guardiola is i think he's amazing
he will have the most trophies he will
finish his career the most successful
manager in the history of football he'll
have done it in different countries
the reason why i would still go with sir
alex ferguson
is it not just to do with the premier
league but
the same managing jose's one i think
klopp's one it's the one thing pep
hasn't done
is almost win with an inferior team or
maybe when you're up against the odds
that's the only thing now
managing the great players managing the
great teams is is obviously a skill in
itself but i think of what sort of
joel's even in the champions league with
porto or alex ferguson what he did with
aberdeen
klopp what he did with sort of dortmund
i'm not saying all these managers are
better than pep guardiola but in terms
of alex ferguson
how long he was in the premier league
where manchester united were when he
came in
you know to be the guy who won that
first title and then keep it going i'd
still have ceramics ferguson ahead of
pep guardiola i think there was a stat
yesterday with pep
if he wins the league this year he won
10 of the last 13 league titles which is
amazing my goodness and i know there's
an argument he's always but i think
that's his that's because he's clever
he's not gone to a team that people go
well he's always had money to spend he's
always with the both players the best
play that's because he's switched on
he's thinking yeah i want to walk with
the best even go back to barcelona he
first got in there with the reserves and
he's walking the first as you said we
should have to win and people go well
he's at barcelona it's easy to win no i
don't other barcelona managers haven't
won that much lords have been sacked so
he's managed that group even well and of
course he's clever going to
and manchester city how does that feel
when you think we've got the best
manager did you always have that feeling
uh probably yeah probably but doesn't
guarantee you as you said you still have
to go out and do the business but it
gives you a bit of a chance
the way i look at the managers i played
for but the two outstanding managers
obviously who backed up with trophies i
suppose it was obviously brian clough
and alex ferguson is do i look at it
whatever about their personalities and
whatever my relationship with them
i never wanted to let them down that was
the key i never and you know it was the
same with the other managers of course
but when you're backing up with trophies
you're looking and i spent my longest
period of time with those two managers
i never want to let them down whatever
about traits they had or
the coaching skills because actually
didn't do much coaching
now i'm not seeing every player nothing
for us like brian clough for every
player man united like alex ferguson but
i just know from my own experience when
brian cluff gave me that chance i didn't
want to let him down that was it brian
clough was nothing in forrest he was in
a sense at the time he felt bigger than
the club and you could say the same for
ferguson sometimes he'd back you he'd
fight your corner about a contract
situation but ultimately i kind of lost
that respect at the end when i felt you
know you threw me under the bus but in
my in all my playing time there you have
to go out and try and do your best but
then again jamie aren't you supposed to
do that you know what i mean yeah
i think even if you i had my stuff with
arnold and nick mccarthy but but i never
went on the pitch even with
disagreements or not happy with certain
and not giving my best you have to
but yeah not wanting to let these
managers down you know what time 3-3
when you had disagreements with managers
or you felt they'd let you down in a
certain way do you look back years later
and say well that's that's the
ruthlessness a manager needs or do you
feel you will have to handle those
things left down yeah definitely not
nothing will change my mind or not
no
and we talk about disagreements i'm
probably looking at
two big disagreements in my career when
was in the world cup and was my time at
united it's not as it was you know hear
about players following up with managers
every week that certainly wasn't me i
was you ask anyone who's worked with me
i was like yeah well
i'd like to think i was law maintenance
i thought i was but come the end when
attack managers are really disrespecting
me and throwing me under the bus that's
where i went
no no no so i've never lost a wink
asleep over that chair i haven't
honestly and i i know listen we all do
stuff we look back we've made mistakes
i've never said we look back and go and
i got that but on the kind of big
occasions of my career where
again the world cup when i left united i
don't look back at any stage you think i
got that wrong absolutely not
but
obviously it takes two to tango
roy keane was the greatest captain in
premier league history
three
two
jesus come on no no no no come on i
i have to say that jesus christ oh this
is some i got back
i i would say you were the greatest
captain in premier league history you're
saying disagree who else would you say
was the the other sort of ones you
looked at and admired i like i told you
i was good i talked vincent company down
by lemon city to adams i don't know i
think there's
i think the captain's seeing the kind of
story behind it and because we had a bit
of success i honestly i cringe at stuff
like this i just think it's
a bit over the top
i i think the other one i would put up
there alongside was i sort of
john teddy yeah yeah and i i always
looked at you as that sort of driving
force of you know what you'd associate a
captain sort of being maybe in an
old-fashioned sort of sense of you know
screaming shouting at the referee their
own players always involved in the game
but again anybody goes back if you win
one or two trophies people think they
maybe give you more credit than what you
deserve they think oh you led them you
go
don't worry they've won a lot they've
been plenty games that are not playing
or when you leave they're going to win
trophies it's just i think when you've
got good senior players around
i think that's sticky i it can't be
certainly down to one player i know
there's different
captaincy carries more weight in
different sports and cricket whatever it
might be even rugby i think the soccer
once you five or six good senior players
i think that takes care of it the key
for me is always is train properly and
try and be a decent decent player and
more importantly is a decent teammate
and not be some idiot around the place
and you know you you might mention their
other captains from other clubs but i
look at other captains or other clubs
and and sometimes when i see what
they're up to away from football i don't
like all actually i mean not that i've
got a halo above my head but i think
when you're a captain you've got to be a
kind of decent lad in a dress room and
listen be
be up for a night out or fight lads
can't their contracts you know if
they're up
even in a bit of balance
forget the contract no but if you're
you're in the trenches with these lads
and again the key for me is when you
speak to we mentioned earlier when you
meet
annie your ex teammates i hope and you
hopefully the same when you meet on your
ex teammates you hope they're looking
and go you're a decent teammate you want
perfect or again you want pals at all of
them and i i hope the lads outplayed
with it we saw tim howard yesterday i
met you look at tim you go we had good
memories together that was it and you
hoped that you were when you were in the
trenches
they had a bit of respect here was it
was liking yeah but a bit of respect for
you was it special lifting those
trophies as well was that something that
you got so much out of honestly sounds
bizarre i probably shouldn't be doing
this chat i never got a buzz from all
that stuff i was never
not i remember i think we won the title
at everton and lauren blanc was retired
and i said to the manager i think i
think let lauren pick the trophy up you
know he says la the manager was no no no
you pick it up you're the captain
so i wasn't even bothered with stuff
that really wasn't me because i was
always thinking don't enjoy it too much
you know just keep focused and it's
always next year and don't let people
think you're relaxing the biggest
pressure i found at united obviously
with the capstone was
small little things like uh the match
days tickets
lounge tickets oh and that came to the
captain i'd like to think the game has
changed nobody ever probably player
liaison officer doing all that but i was
i found that hard because i was usually
trying to get about 50 for all the irish
forget about the game i'm going to get
my tickets but then people get in touch
going we actually don't want to take it
for the game we want to take her for the
lounge not even what about the
but yeah could i enjoy them more you're
the same no i wouldn't change anything
but that's why you know i go back to i
feel sorry for mcguire if you're going
to a big club it's like imagine if i
came to my united
st that doesn't say much about the rest
of the group surely someone's got to be
at the club a number of years too you
should be the captain at united united
now
oh well that's should they have one yeah
but the fact no the fact we've got to
discuss or think about is not good
it's not good
but it's not good that mcguire's got it
because again he was only new to the
club himself a couple years ago and he's
still getting used to it and all of a
sudden he's got the extra responsibility
when he was trying to find his feet
keane and richards are a better punditry
jew than neville and carragher
[Laughter]
that's a great one
[Applause]
let me read that properly
no
[Music]
yeah
trying to get a few answers out of deal
yeah
no let's be honest i
i think whatever that ponder we're all
different again different personalities
you and obviously gary are obviously
well established well experienced
and you're you're bloody good at your
job in it and i think people don't
realize that when you're doing your job
a good year but i think part of my issue
a little bit i still feel like i'm
dipping into it whereas you where you
and gary obviously will establish you
know what you're doing
um
i don't know but enjoy it i i wouldn't
go that far i like watching games and i
like giving my opinion i like working
with skye and itv and i feel lucky and
but i don't i still don't feel it is
that's my my job do you know what i mean
whereas maybe because i've been involved
in a bit of course did you still feel
like
a manager doing pundits you're waiting
to go back into management i i did up to
recently but i i almost feel recently i
think that that
them days are over for me now i think
going back into management i really feel
like i'm 50 no i'm doing the tv
uh obviously label i'm more of a pundit
now
um
but no no i feel i'm getting my head
around it it's maybe more of a head job
that maybe that is the role for me over
the next few years i think
i can't see a club really give me a
really good opportunity uh to get back
into it so
but i don't mind that either i'm not
fearful of going well you might do the
tv for next two or three years i'm fine
with that because i do caught my
blessings because i know as you know
there's a lot of ex players looking to
get back into it and um
yeah i'm okay with that you've gone back
to this the pundits are you and gary
obviously and if it's
like a we do love the game and we give
our opinions i'm sure not everyone
agrees you're going into the game aren't
we yeah well i've been going
yeah yeah
but no i think we love the game and
hopefully that you hope that comes
across
and now again we go back to it you're
what i'm working with different people
and i enjoy walking with different
people and it's just it's bizarre people
can get upset with a pundit's opinion
here we go it's just our opinions
i don't care if they're managing the
best thing is when they get upset when
you haven't even given an opinion so i
was commentating at a city liverpool and
the referee gave a bad decision uh
against city i know the crowd going bad
man i said i'm not the referee
[Laughter]
he's a decent guy and again
the key for me i go back into all my you
want to work with good people aren't you
and yeah and is gary neville different
in the dressing room as he is on tv yeah
gary was gary was a lot quieter i know
gary seems i seem surprised every time i
say that but yeah he was quiet but
whether he got a bit more vocal after i
left i don't know obviously gary became
the captain uh but he seems he seems to
have a lot more to say for himself at
the moment but that's gary again gary's
a nice guy he's a nice nice background
filled with the same nah yeah are you
working gary
it's not a joke
gary's a good guy and obviously you get
unwell with him and you come across well
and and that's sticky you know you i
think
to answer the it was the first question
who was better if you've got to choose
one of the three one of the sky boys as
a number two in management you're going
back into management you've got to pick
one of carriger uh richards and neville
as your number two who are you taking
um
probably take jeremy but you said you
you've no interest whatsoever getting
involved in coaching no but
personality-wise i'd probably take uh
i'd probably take jeremy i think he'd be
i think he'd be good with players be
hands-on
yeah you'd be like believe it or not you
might enjoy it
you might you've said that to me before
you might if lads are doing this session
you don't have to be bibs and corns man
some people aren't like that and i'm not
like that but you might like walking
with players and good young players if
you have a good group um but if you're
with a bad group like a lot of managers
are
that's where it's tough and stressful i
think i'd find that tough if i felt
there was a group of players
who didn't want to win as much as me and
i think you've you've spoke to me about
that and that that's something that you
find a problem in a dressing room i
found that a problem in my own dressing
when i was a player really that used to
really frustrate me and i almost i don't
think you can ever want to win too much
but that was me it was almost the be all
and end-all but if you have a good group
chairman yeah it's the best job in the
world you know it's the best job of
school for
win loser draw it wouldn't bottom even
when i was a player united whatever you
wouldn't lose a lot of matches but as
long as you gave everything you have
that's great
brilliant and kind of still missed that
side of us but when you've got bad lads
in a bad dressing room or it's torture
torture gary neville talks too much
three
two
one
easy
i've never met anyone like
gary neville
in terms of
he just feels like he's got a million
things going on at once and i never even
mentioned this soon yesterday but we've
been
busy we're on the pitch at four o'clock
so we do our thing so it's ten past four
the game taken off at 4 30 we've then
got to get up so we're getting up
through the different lifts we get down
we've got to sort our head set on mike's
so we've probably got two or three
minutes and he's got his laptop out up
and i'm thinking he's going on the snap
pack
so i've just looked what he's doing his
email
and he's sending an email over this
hotel
and i'm thinking
this game's kicking off in like two or
three minutes and it's like something at
the top say my cause is something like a
hotel saint michaels he's got us up in
manchester and he's reading this email
i'm thinking what is going on it is easy
but i i admire gary no i do not for that
type not with you that would annoy me
because i think it's 5 10 minutes this
is our priority the game
but he does multitask and i see him for
all his roles would it be with salford
the hotels guy to me one of them jobs is
your only job but he's got loads going
on whether he's missing something
upstairs he's
he's lacking something obviously sleep
sleep yes sleepy i think there's a bit
of madness to gary yeah there's
definitely been a madness that he can
but part of me then i admire him because
he's multitasking did he said the other
day before the game he just flew back
from miami or something did you get back
from miami and in qatar the week before
what was he doing at guitar what's he
saying with the whale cough trying to
make a few shillings
so he does i admire where he gets his
energy from but
he'd be
what about him now doesn't does a new
role for him now isn't he's going into
politics is that what he's gone yeah
gary
do you see him is he was he like a
politician
gary never you never said a word
[Laughter]
you're chatting and gary says
yeah you'd be quiet
you're a full-back you know i mean stay
in your lane no no it's amazing how he's
he's changed i don't know what's
happened to him
but apparently he admires him because
i'm thinking he's doing all these big
jobs
but he'll he'll crash and burn
good luck
good luck cheers
[Applause]
hey that was a good person
to see the ones i used to bubble into
[ __ ]
united's travel in 1999
is the greatest achievement by an
english cub
three
two
one
trouble i've got to strongly agree
i have to that
99 was just